the real-life MBA you are I don't know
what this means your no BS guide to
winning the game building a team and
growing your career Jack and Suzy Welch
with a Suzy there's a part back in the
book which which is not touchy-feely but
it talks about emotion and about being
happy about getting to the right job a
lot of us are miserable I'm honored and
every day I wake up and go you're
kidding they're gonna pay me to do this
how cool but there's a lot of people
that don't have that Jack and I wrote a
column together called how to know when
it's time to quit your job we got a
million hits I mean people are hungry
too so is it time for me to quit my job
you don't read that if you're happy in
your job okay so I mean we talked about
the whole last third of the book is
about careers and there's a section of
what should you do with your life we
travel around in people people who are
working a good job say I don't think I'm
doing the right thing with my life and
so we give a construct called the area
of destiny to help you figure out if
you're actually in the right profession
LinkedIn is a constructive force yes
years ago you would have used it as a
tool I want to ask about this you know
making decisions about what you want to
do with your life you say business is a
game you have to be enjoying it you have
to want to win it but there's another
decision that we all have to make which
is how much of our lives do we want to
put into the game that is business and
how much of our lives do we want to put
into this other part of it which is a
family which has nothing to do with what
he sees you it's a personal choice yours
is different than mine given Suzy's what
if it's different from the management at
your company right then you got to think
about whether you're at the right
company your values your personal values
have got to agree with the values of
your company or it's gonna be like this
every single day because of your company
values availability
okay people get promoted because of it
they value let you know that you're
always on you're always there and you
don't and you want to have a real
bifurcation between working life you
gotta go to a company where your values
match or its [ __ ] it's gonna be war
okay
you think people these days I mean
particularly in their 20s are just
expecting too much satisfied
no we don't agree with that we go with
we think that that's a lot a lot of bunk
wit seeing wonderful kids in their 20s
hungry nose against the grass and we've
been to a lot of schools now our control
room is full of them entitlement all
that stuff well you go back to this now
with Marissa Meyer page 163
well well well Marissa might as well
have gone on to insult puppies and
rainbows given the outrage Jack Welch I
miss Marissa Mayer there's a huge debate
about her future yeah well well we're
talking here about her decision to bring
people in look she's in a war she's got
these people in jammies at home working
from home and she said love it regular
take the sights of the competition we
need to be all hands on deck who is the
American CEO who's getting this right we
there's so many there's so many and
companies large and small Jack I've got
to ask you about this this new split off
of yeah II capital it's got to be an
emotional thing for you is mr. email
doing the right thing
Industrial like taking GE back to
Pittsfield and it's connecting he's made
a call that the regulatory environment
no leverage
dodd-frank City these rules don't make
cheese capitalist attractive as it was
now he's keeping 90 billion dollars of
assets so it's still a substantial
financial services company but it's
servicing the industrial part of the
company but his industrials different
than urinals dollars look what you think
it's the same same exact look what did I
won't want to be I want to be number one
of the aircraft engines number one in
power number one in medical number one
and a lot of motors in transportation
and we and we were not when we started
and we got there when I retired let's
come back Suzy Welch fired up here the
real life MBA Brendan and I looked at
and said yeah yeah yeah Jack you know
the golf game was off so he had to write
this unfortunately I have to tell you
this is fabulous
it is it's incredibly blunt that is that
it was it is like very cool the
real-life MBA Jack Welch and Suzy on the
battles of doing better in our modern
society